[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerradas
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
nicaragua con los nuevos ataques de
daniel ortega a la disidencia para ello
me acompañan en este estudio pascal duro
o vicepresidente del instituto psoas o
el especialista en relaciones
internacionales y presidente de la
asociación la de fran francia américa
latina bienvenido pascal buenos días
alan riding ex corresponsal de new york
times' en américa latina' bienvenido a
land gracias y nos acompañan en
distancia a distancia en dúplex maya
colom von catedrática en el instituto de
ciencias políticas de lyon especializada
en política nicaragüense maya buenos
días buenos días gracias a que imparten
es politólogo especialista en
centroamérica que bien buenos días
buenos días es un gran gusto hacer parte
de su programa
nicaragua hoy es nuestro asunto en
primera plana
la persecución política de nuevo en
nicaragua al menos 19 opositores entre
periodistas y antiguos aliados del
gobierno han sido detenidos por la
policía nacional órgano que responde a
daniel ortega y a la vicepresidenta a su
esposa rosario murillo
cinco de ellos aspiran a ser candidatos
presidenciales en las elecciones de
noviembre pero ortega per busca
permanecer en el poder como sea
organismos internacionales han exigido
que se lleven a cabo elecciones
transparentes y justas vamos a analizar
esta nueva crisis política en nicaragua
un país que si recuerdan ya estuvo en el
foco mundial hace justo tres años en
2018 cuando estalló la gran crisis
política que aún arrastra el país pero
antes de ello repasemos algunas portadas
diario la prensa de nicaragua régimen
continúa redadas opositores en españa'
el país
ortega contra todos los blancos de la
nueva embestida contra la oposición en
nicaragua el confidencial exterminio
político de los opositores bueno
pascal no sé si estamos asistiendo a
esto que decían en la prensa un antiguo
exterminio político de la oposición de
nicaragua bueno pienso que estamos
viviendo un pasaje en fuerza
de daniel ortega y de la pareja ortega
murió en un contexto que favorece un
regreso a una forma de autoritarismo
inédito nuevo en un país que por cierto
y bien lo he visto tuvo un enfoque
particular hace unos años en 2018 cuando
una represión de las manifestaciones de
movimientos sociales pero también en un
país que perteneció la historia hace
unos diseños en un contexto
internacional totalmente diferente de
hoy en día hoy en día ortega saca
provecho de una fragmentación de américa
central donde está la integración
centroamericana desde que empezó la
crisis de la comida que reveló las
fracturas sociales las fracturas
económicas de los países de américa
latina las cifras globales lo demuestran
200 millones de personas caen viven en
la pobreza en un continente que cuenta
600 millones y obviamente ortega pues
saca provecho de esa situación hoy en
día estamos viviendo un combate
entre la legalidad tiene una legalidad
técnica y lo vemos a través de las leyes
contra la libertades que están votando y
por las cuales está impulsando
apoyándose sobre esa política
definitivamente de represión y la
legitimidad seguramente muy realmente
por la de todo lo demás la perdió desde
tres años adelante factores explica en
esta esta redada de ortega a los
disidentes es un episodio más sobre la
crisis de 2018 ampliada ahora
ciertamente pero él nunca tenía la
intención de irse él esperaba como en
las otras ocasiones las cosas se pasaran
tranquilamente porque ya tenía control
sobre todos los instrumentos de poder
del país la legislatura de la judiciaria
la policía el ejército entonces
se suponía que las cosas andaban andaban
la economía andaba relativamente bien
él tenía buenas relaciones con los
empresarios tenía buenas relaciones con
la iglesia todas cosas que eran
contrario a ser un revolucionario de la
izquierda pero en fin entonces parecía
ir bien entonces está allá porque es
como como una buena parte de américa
latina' buena buena parte del mundo el
tipo de crecimiento que hubo en aquellos
años del 56 por ciento es cierto fue
distorsionada fue controlada con por un
pequeño grupo entonces está allá y en
este momento él tiene que empezar a usar
los instrumentos y se habla de leyes
buenos leyes eso es también otra ficción
américa latina y que hace pegarle una
persona se escribe una ley después le
pega no entonces ahora inventado que es
la tradición aunque que la intervención
es extranjera pero él nunca tenía la
intención de irse entonces ahora el
costo de quedarse ha aumentado el costo
interno para para la oposición y para el
pueblo en general
y el costo externo más presión del
exterior pero que se quede que se quede
maya colombo catedrática en ciencias
políticas especializada en política
nicaragüense en ciencias políticas de
lyon pese a las presiones
internacionales
daniela ortega continúa su caza de
disidentes su escenario de tener vía
libre sin oposición en las elecciones de
noviembre va a rumbo de concretarse o
algo le puede impedir esto
claramente lo que ha hecho el gobierno
de ortega murillo
encarcelando a las mayores figuras de la
oposición poner esta oposición en
situación de bloqueo total varias leyes
la ley 10 55 que es la que criminaliza
la mayoría de los oponentes políticos
hoy en día pero otras leyes han ido
modificándose de manera a consolidar
este régimen autoritario y permitir a la
presidencia al gobierno hacer que
si van a poner a algún oponente en la
cárcel tienen el derecho legal gracias a
la reforma del código penal de mantener
a estos prisioneros en la cárcel por
hasta 90 días quiere decir que en estas
circunstancias todos los presos
políticos o los oponentes políticos que
están en residencia
y controladas no pueden salir para ir a
presentarse frente al consejo supremo
electoral a finales de julio entonces
digamos que lo más probable en estas
circunstancias es que él
la oposición no tenga candidatos
y que se puedan oficialmente presentar
al consejo supremo electoral para estar
en las listas de las elecciones de
noviembre
a pesar de que el clima de represión e
incertidumbre ha ido escalando desde
2018 los empresarios habían permanecido
mayoritariamente en silencio hoy la
persecución les ha alcanzado también a
la clase empresarial que sea un poco una
novedad no desde la deriva de ortega
porque ortega también va por ellos ahora
pues pues que está definitivamente
bloqueando todos los espacios en la
perspectiva de la presidencia del 7 de
noviembre próximo y porque se siente
fuerte porque tiene control del aparato
económico del país y de todos los
sectores a pesar de una situación
extremadamente difícil el nivel de
crecimiento bajo por supuesto desde ya
varios años estamos a menos 3.5 por
ciento y bueno tiene control entonces ya
se siente fuerte y es realmente este
pasaje en fuerza
pero también hay la pregunta es por qué
la empresa privada empieza a tomar
posiciones y eso también buscando a
largo plazo salvarse lo hicieron
consumado se vivieron consumos durante
décadas con la más tranquilidad pero
cuando se empezó a derrumbar el país
cuando la revolución empezó a acelerarse
entonces pasaron del otro rodado porque
se veían por donde iba la cosa eso se ve
muchas veces en américa latina es decir
hay que buscar venezuela hasta con
brasil lula la empresa privada se busca
es un lugar también en un nuevo región
en una nueva situación entonces de
repente por the globe per te los tenía y
yo comprados y ahora están buscando
otros entonces hay que aplazarlos le voy
a preguntar a que imparten es politólogo
especialista de centroamérica quienes
son los detenidos hasta ahora sobre todo
qué perfiles encontramos entre ellos
kevin
hay dos tipos de detenidos que se pueden
identificar hoy que corresponden a dos o
las distintas primero hay la ola de la
detención que toca más bien a los
precandidatos son hoy en día 5 y que
corresponde a una estrategia de daniel
ortega de limpiar la planilla y no tener
competición real para la elección que
viene la segunda ola es más bien la la
ola que estamos viviendo muy reciente es
una serie de detenciones que afectan
intelectuales personas muy conocidas
reconocidas en el país que tienen una
historia que tienen un peso simbólico
por su trayectoria y me voy a diferir
por ejemplo al caso de dora maria teles
que es ex combatiente sandinista que
después sido una opositora daniel ortega
fundando el movimiento de renovación
sandinista y eso es como una etapa
máxima en el proceso de deriva del poder
y del rechazo
tipo de oposición del discurso
contradictorio y de fortalecimiento de
una oposición de una contradicción desde
la sociedad civil
pascal adam y la comunidad internacional
qué papel puede jugar aquí porque parece
que la presión
ortega aparece que le da igual hasta qué
punto por ejemplo en los eeuu que poder
de influencia tienen toda esta crisis
muy poca influencia en la práctica tiene
que hacer sus cositas es decir sus
comentarios cada
cada vez que se le pregunta qué pasará
no nos apoyamos
regresamos las detenciones todo el
programa vender para los estados ciento
indica la vez que quiere la estabilidad
estaba contento no les preocupaba ni a
trump ni a obama que había una dictadura
en nicaragua aunque se porque funcionaba
más o menos lo que más le preocupa es
que es una gran desestabilización de
nicaragua tipo venezuela que sé
que se junta con lo que está pasando en
el guatemala el salvador y honduras y
eso lo quieren evitar como sea eso es el
punto más importante que no hay otro
500.000 el centroamericanos pegando la
puerta en texas
definitivamente kamala harris acaba de
hacer un viaje importante en
centroamérica y en guatemala llamando
pues los migrantes en quedarse en su
país creo que eso fue muy importante
porque como lo acaba de decir a la cndh
el tema migratorio es un tema para los
eeuu pero tampoco solamente eeuu no
quiere que vuelvan unos focos de de
estabilización a sus fronteras sur
aunque estemos
hoy en día en un mundo nuevo donde
nuevos actores integraron en el mapa
centro latinoamericano centroamericano
pienso la china pienso en rusia
obviamente pienso en demás países como
turquía es decir que estamos en un nuevo
mapa internacional y ortega
definitivamente al final de este tercer
periodo consecutivo y llamando a una
nueva elección para noviembre pues saca
provecho de eso es cierto que tiene ese
instrumento pero a la vez la comunidad
internacional tiene obvia obviamente un
peso lo vemos a través de los últimos
acontecimiento en eeuu donde se acaba de
adoptar el renacer act de la comisión de
asuntos exteriores del senado ya
haciendo llamando a unas sanciones sobre
personas sobre actores claves en el
poder es decir que son gestos ademanes
que por supuesto deben llamar la
atención de la opinión pública
nicaragüense voy a hacer una breve pausa
y en instantes continuamos analizando la
situación en nicaragua quien en primera
plana
[Música]
y
para muy buenas noches regresamos con
más noticias para este nuevo avance
informativo que comenzamos en eeuu y es
que los equipos de emergencia siguen
tratando de encontrar a más
sobrevivientes tras el derrumbe parcial
de un edificio residencial de 12 plantas
ocurrido durante la madrugada del jueves
pasado en miami las autoridades locales
confirmaron que hasta el momento fueron
encontrados cuatro cuerpos sin vida
mientras que cerca de 160 personas
permanecen desaparecidas el presidente
el demócrata joe biden aprobó una
declaración de emergencia para el estado
de la florida y ordenó además la
asistencia federal a los familiares de
las personas desaparecidas viven horas
de tensión y de angustia
quiero decir resignación solo confiar en
dios que cualquier milagro puede ocurrir
no sólo para mí sino para todos los que
están sufriendo lo mismo
masnoticias de eeuu la justicia de
minnesota condenó a 22 años y medio de
prisión a derecho bien estamos hablando
del ex policía que asesinó al hombre
afroamericano george freud en mayo de
2020 jobim pasará 15 años en la cárcel y
siete y medio en prisión domiciliaria y
le descontaron además los 199 días que
duró el juicio tras el que fue declarado
culpable de tres delitos los abogados de
este ex agente policial tienen 90 días
ahora para apelar la decisión el
asesinato recordemos generó una ola de
manifestaciones y se transformó en todo
un símbolo del racismo sistémico y de la
violencia policial en eeuu no obstante
los miembros de la familia floyd pedían
la pena máxima y se manifestaron
descontentos con esa condena
y en otras noticias en su gira por
europa que ya lo llevó a alemania el
secretario de estado estadounidense
anthony blinken fue recibido en parís
pons homologó es lesbiana y más tarde
por el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón y nuestra corresponsal en la
capital francesa
erika olavarría nos trae las
conclusiones que deja al momento esta
visita diplomática escuchemos bienvenido
a casa de esta manera recibió en parís a
el ministro de exteriores francés yves
le drían a su homólogo estadounidense
anthony blinken y es que el americano
vivió aquí diez años habla perfectamente
francés terminó en parís la secundaria y
ambos hombres son amigos desde el año
2012 esa amistad no impidió que tocarán
temas espinosos en esta reunión
empezando por el acuerdo nuclear con
irán brinquen recordó a teherán que eeuu
no va a reintegrar este acuerdo si las
discusiones se eternizan también se
refirieron a china para eeuu la
principal amenaza en el mundo de hoy
ledian recordó a blink en que francia no
es partidaria de un enfrentamiento con
el gigante asiático a través de la otan
y se refirieron también a rusia
y sober a eeuu que francia y europa
quieren conversar de igual a igual con
moscú blinken dijo que no tomarán
ninguna decisión sin consultar a europa
ambos hombres fueron juntos hasta el
palacio del elíseo donde el jefe de la
diplomacia eeuu tuvo el privilegio de
ser recibido por el presidente emmanuel
macrón tras esta reunión no hubo
declaraciones a basamos ahora con
noticias de américa latina y es que
colombia alcanzó cifras récord de
cultivos de hojas de coca y también de
producción de cocaína en el año 2020
esto según la oficina de política
nacional de control de drogas de eeuu
según esta entidad durante el primer año
de la pandemia de coronavirus los
esfuerzos para reducir estas actividades
se vieron impactados por el aumento de
la violencia en estas regiones
productoras y por las altas tasas de
contagios por el virus del cob y 19 el
gobierno colombiano por su parte reportó
que en 2020 también hubo récord en la
erradicación manual de cultivos ilícitos
hasta aquí llegamos con este avance
informativo sigan estas 24 y en
transmití cuatro.com
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio de 2020 un millón más de
hogares nos ven en perú con esto en
américa latina' más de 93 millones de
hogares reciben nuestra señal más otros
12 millones en difusión parcial en
mexico la señal de televisión de france
24 en español llega a 19 países de las
américas desde estados unidos hasta
argentina a través de 36 operadores de
cable durante la pandemia del
coronavirus más y más personas buscan
informarse en france 24 en español en
marzo de 2020 registramos 43 millones de
visitas en nuestro sitio web casi 5
veces más que en 2019 14 7 millones de
visitas en nuestras plataformas
digitales en especial en teléfonos
móviles
estamos en youtube facebook twitter
instagram
nuestros vídeos registran 123 millones
de vistas a nuestras audiencias gracias
por su fidelidad
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana analizando la crisis política de
nuevo instalada en nicaragua con ese
trasfondo electoral lo hacemos compras
carl drews vicepresidente el instituto
sol especialista en relaciones
internacionales y presidente de la
asociación la fran con alan reading ex
corresponsal del new york times' en
américa latina y en dúplex nos acompañan
los politólogos especialistas en
centroamérica maya colombo y que parte
me bueno a la crisis política de 2018
hay que sumarle ahora el contexto nuevo
lo nuevo que hay la pandemia de la cob y
19 acompañada de los huracanes se lo
recuerdan yota jetta que también
hicieron estragos en la producción
nacional
este hecho claro aumentar
considerablemente todavía más la pobreza
en el país en una situación todavía más
desesperada bueno eso sí está claro hay
dos posibilidades una es más gente y lo
que ha pasado en américa central también
a los huracanes sobre todo y también
kobe pero ha aumentado la presión
migratoria hacia el norte
pero también la pobreza de por si existe
y no no necesariamente es lo que lo que
estalla estos movimientos son sobre todo
un movimiento político y no está ha ido
por por pobreza lamentablemente entonces
lo hemos visto en muchas partes del
mundo entonces yo creo que si se ve
muchas perdón produce más miseria
sencillamente produce más miseria pero
no hay no hay efectos inmediatos que
vayan a producir un resultado más
positivo hablando de la disidencia le
voy a preguntar amaya colom von destaca
en esa licencia la figura de la
periodista cristiana chamorro su
principal rival sobre el papel de de
ortega que perfil trazaremos podremos
trazar de ella cristiana chamorro tiene
una primera peculiaridad es que es la
hija de violeta chamorro que fue
presidente de la república a partir de
1990 es también
la presidenta que ganó o sea la
candidata mejor dicho que ganó la
elección de 1990 contra daniel ortega y
que le pone fin a su primer mandato
presidencial
entonces para
daniel ortega y rosario murió hoy en el
poder es muy simbólico de poner a
cristiana chamorro hija de la que hizo
que perdieron las elecciones y perdieron
el poder en 1990 en pues en situación de
no poderse presentar a esta elección es
una figura que trasciende un poquito
podríamos decir nos darán los dos
grandes grupos de oposición que existe
es hoy en día en nicaragua la alianza
ciudadana de la coalición nacional
cristiana chamorro ella se presenta como
candidata independiente por su posición
era decir que ella se presentaba al día
de esa pose de esta fractura que existe
dentro de la oposición
organizaciones como human right watch
piden a la onu que endurezca su
respuesta a la crisis de nicaragua se
puede esperar ese incremento de la
presión de la comunidad internacional
hacia ortega en las próximas semanas
según nos vayamos acercando a esa fecha
electoral pascal definitivamente pero
cuáles van a ser los productos porque ya
vimos que eso por cierto es un mensaje a
la comunidad internacional en términos
de imagen pero lo vimos con venezuela y
qué
entonces hace parte de un todo
definitivamente la clave lo tienen los
nicaragüenses y esa es la razón por la
cual la movilización internacional pero
que es lo que llamamos también la
comunidad internacional
hoy en día en esa fragmentación
internacional ya que daniel ortega
cuenta cuenta también con unos aliados
el puede también criticar la comunidad
internacional diciendo bueno esa tiene
vocación en tener apoyo es lo que hace
de los eeuu y ya manda otra vez aa la
retórica de los años 70 80
revolucionarios llamó yo daniel ortega
una liberación de la comunidad
internacional porque aquí estamos para
el bien del pueblo etcétera hay toda esa
retórica pero definitivamente una
movilización internacional que la unión
europea la unión europea es presente en
centroamérica desde el ocio es 80 los
acuerdos de san josé los acuerdos en
dulce en burgos en el principio de los
80 organizaron es actualizar presencia
muy fuerte primer actor en materia de
apoyo al desarrollo de centroamérica
ahora
no creo que tenga mucho impacto
honestamente se ve por todos lados del
mundo es mi alma
turquía venezuela cuba rusia china o sea
que la clave la clave como decía pascal
está en los propios nicaragüenses así
pero ahí viene la pregunta porque yo lo
yo me pregunté hace 50 años que cubrían
nicaragua es decir hay otra opción que
la lucha armada la gente está obligada a
encontrarse en esta situación en que la
vía democrática ya no funciona no hay
apoyo no hay apoyo para hacer hacer que
funcione donde puede estar la salida que
es el foco de esperanza puede haber hace
45 años la esperanza era la lucha armada
hoy en día nadie quiere eso pero al
mismo tiempo la frustración en un
momento dado ahora hay una diferencia
que la estructura de poder de ortega es
mucho más eficaz que la estructura de
militar de somoza no cabe duda es decir
desde el inicio los cubanos estaban en
la primera época la reducción
organizando toda la estructura de
seguridad de inteligencia como lo han
hecho
y están ahí todavía hoy en día no les
importa la ideología el hecho de que
decir que ortega es un revolucionario no
tiene ninguna importancia es decir es
aliado aún no es cierto él puede contar
tal vez en rusia y en menos venezuela
porque si contaba mucho del crecimiento
económico y dependía mucho de la ayuda
económica y de petróleo de venezuela
pero es este tipo de acuerdo interesante
por ejemplo había este nicaragua
venezuela cuba bolivia hacia tu momento
correa en el ecuador
eso ya no es tan claro esta semana los
gobiernos de méxico y de argentina
gobiernos de dizque de izquierda se
retiraron sus embajadas son sus
embajadores de managua es decir ya
empezaron a distanciarse entonces al
respecto de que es es una una reducción
de izquierda que se está luchando a
sobrevivir ya nadie lo quería el aspecto
romántico
y vamos a volver con kevin parte el
politólogo especialista en centroamérica
porque le quiero preguntar que la crisis
política con los 400 muertos de 2018
puso todos los focos a nivel
internacional en nicaragua todos los
periodistas lo conocemos bien luego ya
el foco se va y qué pasa entre medias
pues le voy a preguntar a kevin qué ha
pasado desde entonces en el país durante
estos tres años pues dice usted de abril
es más bien una secuencia que intenta
salir del conflicto se puede por ejemplo
ver las tentativas de establecer como
comisiones de la paz es un periodo que
se caracterizó más bien por la presión
internacional por intentos por varios
actores que sean internacionales la oea
y dh unas partes de la unión europea
también o estados de estado europeos es
que es ese período fue más bien
encontrar un camino de salida del
conflicto después surgió el kobe
lo que se puede destacar es que
salió surgió una cómo decirlo una un
régimen autoritario con toda su extender
y pues se identificó durante todo este
periodo del cob y desde pues marzo
2020 hasta casi la fecha pues que no
hubo cooperación ninguna por parte del
gobierno y que la población fue dejada
totalmente a sí misma
estamos frente a una dictadura que se
está endureciendo y con una privación de
libertad de derechos con una
continuación de las violaciones de todos
derechos humanos gente a una una mayor
parte de la población
no sé si podríamos explicar un poco cómo
funciona el clan de los ortega cosa que
me parece bastante interesante siempre
se ha dicho o se habla del poder que
puede ejercer la vicepresidenta de la
esposa rosario murillo los hijos cómo
funciona lo que podríamos llamar un clan
un gran político pero eso viene de lejos
porque como bien se dijo daniel ortega
dejó oficialmente la presidencia en el
90 pero finalmente nunca dejó el poder y
eso lo vimos a raíz de los años de
violeta chamorro pero después del pacto
que pasó con arnold dúo alemán
supuestamente liberal y más en los 2000
con enrique bolaños donde finalmente que
gobernaba gobernada desde abajo borre
usando las palabras que usó daniel
ortega pero cuando se fue en el en el 90
es decir que las estructuras de
presencia y de una presencia social
nunca se dejó primero bien no olvidemos
la famosa piñata recuerdo no sé cuándo
se fue de antes de que se fue después la
derrota del de ortega 90 se quedaron un
tiempito y se agarraron todo lo que
podían hacer la famosa piñata de
entonces se quedaron con casas enormes
mansiones coches todo lo que podían
entonces enriquecieron ya entonces toda
esta imagen de los la pureza funcionaria
ya empezó a desmoronarse lo interesante
es una cierta forma como el ortega en
esta en este período de 90 a 2006 se fue
controlando la estructura del partido y
manteniendo una fuerza militar también
aunque se pasó de ser el ejército
popular sandinista a un ejército
nicaragüense y como una persona que
tiene poco carisma yo le conocí unas
veces en unos tipos al que al conocer
los nuevos tipos más bajos más aburridos
había otros como tomás borge quería más
tipo chávez muy abierto a este no y eso
éramos humanos y todo y cómo es que se
fue el quitando el poder a los otros
comandantes porque al inicio era
iguales 9 de la dirección nacional y él
se fue poco a poco y ya para 95 se
estaban yendo contra él
e incluso sergio ramírez en gran
escritor intelectual que había sido su
vicepresidente pero varios comandantes
entonces ya en aquel momento ellos se
dieron cuenta que el poder se había
acumulado del otro lado y ellos nomás
podían formar otro partidito quejarse
pero ya se pasó le voy a preguntar
también amaya como describiríamos las
características de este clan y su visión
del futuro de la política del país si es
un clan muy claramente empezando por la
pareja
daniel ortega presidente su esposa
rosario murillo vicepresidente desde la
última elección presidencial en 2016
cada uno tiene su lugar predeterminado
según dicen los nicaragüenses según el
rosario murillo que es la jefa de este
ordenamiento o familiar en la cual en el
cual algunos hijos están acercarnos del
poder por ejemplo laureano ortega que
fue consejero presidencial
otros están al mando de los medios de
comunicación que son dueños de medios de
comunicación de canal de televisión
especialidades radiodifusión y otros
tienen algún papel más bien en el campo
cultural pero todos en ámbitos que
permite mantener o estar cerca del poder
también es una familia muy rica sea
bienes propiedades empresas el tema es
sobre todo cómo lograr unirse para
mantenerse en el poder
me quedo sin tiempo para más al no ser
que me digan una frase brillante de
sujeto por ver predicado porque me
quedan 20 segundos
bueno ahí lo dejamos porque nos vamos ya
muchísimas gracias a la an
pascal también a amaya colom on ya que
bien parte n por acompañarnos a hacer
esta radiografía extensa de lo que es la
crisis política a nicaragua ya todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana quien en
primera plana gracias